In this lecture,
we continue our discussion of fraud.
We do so by looking at a 1968 Florida case Volks versus Arthur Murray where the
court considered whether misrepresenting statements of opinion could qualify as
fraud.
Volks was a 51 year old widow who desired to become an accomplished dancer.
She spent over $31,000 and that's in 1960 $8 over 16 months on dance lessons
provided by the defendant Arthur Murray incorporated,
relying upon the defendants,
elaborate assurances that she was dramatically improving and would become an
excellent dancer.
The complaint alleged that she was a poor dancer in spite of the instruction and
that the defendant's encouragements were designed to deceive her and inducer
into purchasing additional lessons.
Volk sued to rescind the contracts for all of the lessons paid for but not
completed and for the return of her $31,000 less the cost of lessons that she
had received,
the trial court dismissed or complaint for failure to state a cause of action
and the instant court reversed.
The central issue.
Is this,
may a contract be rescinded for fraud consisting of misrepresenting one's
dancing abilities according to the court?
The answer is yes.
The court began by noting that generally a contract can only be rescinded for
fraud following a misrepresentation of fact.
Usually opinions are not sufficiently falsifiable to give rise to a claim of
misrepresentation.
However,
the court recognized that exceptions exist to this general rule and held that
the rule does not apply where there is a fiduciary relationship between the
parties or where there has been some artifice or trick employed by the
representer or where the parties do not in general deal at arm's length or where
the representi does not have equal opportunity to become apprised of the truth
or falsity of the fact represented.
Further,
the court noted that a statement of a party having superior knowledge may be
regarded as a statement of fact,
although it would be considered as opinion if the parties were dealing on equal
terms applying that principle to the facts at hand.
The court said that it could be reasonably,
suppose that Arthur Murray had superior knowledge unquote about Volks is dancing
ability and potential and since quote,
it would be a reasonable inference from the undenying developments of the
complaint that the flowery you load gms heaped upon her by defendants as a
prelude to her contracting for 1,944 additional hours of instruction proceeded
as much or more from the urge to ring the cash register as from any honest or
realistic appraisal of her dancing prowess or a factual representation of her
progress unquote.
Because of this,
the court held that Volks is stated a legitimate claim and was entitled to quote
her day in court unquote throughout the case.
The judge takes what some might consider to be a disrespectful tone toward the
plaintiff herself.
Saying,
for example,
that quote,
while she first exalted that she was entering the spring of her life,
she finally was awakened to the fact that there was spring,
neither in her life,
nor in her feet unquote.
Volks ends up winning the right to have her day in court,
but she might feel revictimized by the courts.
Salacious characterization that she quote wiled away the pleasant hours
sometimes in a private room absorbing his accomplished sales technique unquote.
On the other hand,
the procedural posture of the case might help explain the court's Innuendos.
This was an appeal from the trial courts order dismissing the complaint for
failure to state a cause of action.
In other words,
the trial court held that even assuming all the facts alleged by the plaintiff
were true,
she wasn't legally entitled to relief.
Therefore,
the court had to take her allegations as true and ask whether put in the light
most favorable to the plaintiff.
They stated an actionable claim
according to section one 59 of the restatement.
A misrepresentation is an assertion that is not in accord with the facts as voke
shows,
a statement of opinion can be a misrepresentation if the parties are in a
special relationship of trust or the speaker has superior knowledge in that
area.
This is captured by section one 69 B of the restatement which says that the
recipient of an opinion is justified in relying on the opinion.
If he quote reasonably believes that as compared with himself,
the person whose opinion is asserted has special skill judgment or objectivity
with respect to the subject matter unquote.
So let's take a look at this quiz.
Adam is looking to buy a new car.
Beatrice Adam's neighbor is trying to convince that I'm to buy her old Ford
focus of a Honda Civic.
She tells Adam,
I think my focus is a great looking car,
better looking car than any Honda civic relying on Beatrice's opinion.
Adam agrees to purchase the Ford Focus from Beatrice later that day.
Adam's teenage daughter tells him that the car is ugly.
Can Adam rescind the contract based on Beatrice's misrepresentation that are
Ford focus was a great looking car.
This is a pretty simple quiz.
The answer is probably not.
Whether a car is good looking or ugly.
As a matter of opinion,
not fact,
Adam would be justified in relying on Beatrice's opinion if your opinion was
fraudulent.
And he reasonably believed that she had some special skill judgment or
objectivity regarding whether a car is good looking or not.
But there no indication that Beatrice his opinion was fraudulent or that Adam
was justified in relying on her opinion.
Sam Buel has argued that criminal fraud functions to deter and punish novel
wrongful acts that evade narrow legal definition and therefore it must remain
it.
The fraud action must remain adaptive.
He says,
quote,
open textured law that grows and innovates in competition with those who seek to
evade.
It appears to be characteristic of any legal order that seeks to control harmful
human behavior,
at least in any society,
mature enough to have a large economy.
Similar literally,
courts have also interpreted misrepresentation in contract law to cover more
than just statements of fact or expressions of opinion.
For example,
a statement might also be literally true but contained false implications in
context.
The classic example of this is the half truth.
In one case,
after repeated inquiries by the buyer about an oil storage facility,
the seller disclosed the existence of one leak but not others of which it
allegedly knew.
The court held that the disclosure of one leak carried with it quote some
implication of exclusivity unquote.
That is an implication that the seller knew of no other leaks.
Courts have also interpreted misrepresentation to include acts of concealment in
failures to disclose.
Concealment is the covering up of some facts such as painting over water,
damage on basement walls or hiding evidence of termite damages as we're about to
discuss and the one of the very next classes.
While concealment is not exactly a falsehood or at least not an express
misrepresentation,
courts have held that such acts constitute actionable false hoods by hearing
implicit misrepresentations.
Once the court has identified an express or implied representation that is
untrue,
there are additional elements still required for a contracting party to
establish the defense and be able to void a contract.
The listener must have justifiably relied on the misrepresentation in deciding
to enter into the contract and the miss representation must be either fraudulent
or material.
The usual effect of wrongful misrepresentation is to render the contract
voidable by the deceived party,
but courts have identified to kind of fraud in the execution as distinguished
from ordinary fraud in the inducement that precludes the formation of any
contract at all.
As an an example is where a party secure is another signature by misrepresenting
the character of the document.
So let's review.
A contract may be rescinded if one party made fraudulent misrepresentations to
induce the other party to agree to the contract.
Generally,
this rule is limited to misrepresentations of fact.
However,
this may be expanded to other kinds of misrepresentations,
such as misrepresentations of professional opinions as demonstrated by Volks
versus Arthur Murray.